Kwasi [ __ ] is one of the best longboard
surfers in the world in fact he could
almost be number one if you take his
story into account quasi learned to surf
in the turbulent Atlantic Ocean
even before he could swim I really
wanted to try the sport for a long time
but obviously I couldn't since I do like
um prolong my time of surfing it was
very very scary I did eventually come
over the fear of not knowing how to swim
and stepping up to going in the water
and being in the water walk on well
can't swim but I was so dedicated that I
look past that longboard surfing is
often seen as more artistic and graceful
than the short board version as a young
boy Kwasi used to sit on the beach and
watch the surfers back then surfing was
seen as more of a white person's domain
but that didn't stop Kwazii
nor did his lack of experience in the
water i sat in the beach watching him
and I was so fascinated these nice guns
that were doing and and they'll come out
and talk about the how nice turns I had
and I felt so out so then I told him
listen I should really want to try it
was like freely and was really stoked
and gave me my first board in suit and
showed me the basics on the beach and
and I was hooked
that was when Kwazii was nine years old
and ever since then he and his surfboard
have been inseparable
he actually surfed for three years
before he even learned to swim all he
had to depend on to save him out in the
water was his board but it wasn't just
any old board
I was lucky my mom actually brought me
aboard which cost her I think close to
800 rent but she managed to get there
for me and I was dead net board is my
life that was a lot of money in the
poverty-stricken Ocean View Township
back then but it was money well invested
gang crime is rife there and many of
kwazii's old friends spent time in jail
it was a good thing because it kept him
busy all the time away from the street
and from the bad things Quay she has
become a popular trainer for affluent
would-be surfers along Cape Town's
beaches he also has sponsoring contracts
but his heart is with ocean view and the
kids there who attend his free lessons
go to school surf because basically when
you serve you get yourself tired you
know and just go out there and just you
in the ocean you understand nothing
nothing is stopping you there that's
what you are free you know that's like
your office and I think that's that was
my that was my call actually even if you
staying in the hood doesn't mean your
dreams are crushed you know there's
still potential anything is possible you
just got to have a vision to be like
crazy to stay out of trouble and do
stuff on your own and go on with your
life
don't do the wrong stuff that is
kwazii's most important message to young
people with donated boards and wetsuits
Kwasi takes the kids down the same path
that he once took on his way to becoming
one of Africa's first world-class
surfers